our elderly folks out there who who wear
the chains for their glasses they're
smart
they're older more experienced and
smarter you'd say elderly i'm like i
have a pair myself
shout out to the youngins with the chain
as well for the glasses okay
hey gq i'm justin h min and these are my
essentials
[Music]
sunscreen or as a scientist like to say
spf
i don't really know what that stands for
i've gotten a lot of questions about my
my skin care routine and i'm very
flattered
anytime someone asked me
i wish i had a better answer for them
when they do it's my my
my panacea for for everything this one
is from neutrogena it's a sensitive skin
face
i use it because
it's good and it's cheap primarily
because it's cheap
and i'm still paying off my college
loans thank you american education
system it's quite liquidy it doesn't
leave any sort of
white streaks i do play a ghost on
television but i don't want to be a
ghost in real life so this comes in very
handy
the trader joe's everything but the
bagel seasoning blend
with everything going on with the
pandemic i've been doing a lot more
cooking and i'm really bad at cooking
fortunately for me
and for society we have the seasoning
that apparently makes everything taste
better i actually love everything bagels
and now i don't need the bagel i can
just have the seasoning i put it on
toast
i put it on avocados
i put it on salmon it's amazing you know
it's actually like hot sauce if you like
hot sauce and you sort of put it on
things it makes everything taste like
the hot sauce and
it's sort of the same situation here you
put this on anything
it tastes like
the everything but
the bagel sesame seasoning blend and
it's great it's really really great
this is a metal boba straw in the past
couple of years
many boba establishments have
transitioned
to
biodegradable straws paper straws
save the turtles i love it i love it at
the same time i hate paper straws they
taste like cardboard
they dissolve i truly can't drink uh
boba properly my friends knowing that i
am obsessed with boba and i love boba
they got me one of these metal straws
sturdy can pierce
through the cup
very efficiently
and i can suck up
my pearls in a very efficient
great way without having the taste of
paper in my mouth i have boba probably
once a day once every two days it's
always the classic milk tea a classic
black milk tea i have to say this
i watched dan levy's
gq10 things
and he did talk about boba as the
resident asian here i have to say and i
have to make the correction because he
made a distinction between bubble tea
and boba i'm here to tell you that
they're exactly the same thing okay
they're different names for the same
thing we just say bubble tea on the east
coast and here in la we say boba so
i love you dan but uh you were wrong
it's an avocado guys
it's an avocado i have a special
relationship to avocados they're my main
source of sustenance as i said i can't
cook but you don't need to cook when you
have an avocado with you every morning
i'll cut one of these babies up usually
put some
everything
but the bagel seasoning on it a squeeze
of a fresh lemon and you're good to go
they have to be perfectly ripe by the
way i i hate nothing more than an unripe
avocado so when i go to the supermarket
what you do is you can actually take
this top off like so and if you see
inside you can see a bit of the color
and you obviously
want to see that it's a solid green
color
um and then you know you you should know
that it's it's getting quite ripe where
it's there obviously the feel of it will
also tell you it's ripe as well you want
it a bit firm but a bit soft that sounds
contradictory but it's not
this one is not the perfect color for
ripeness as you can see there's still a
bit of green on the outside you want to
get a bit of a darker color all around
to make sure that it's perfectly ripe
and there it is haas avocados or bust
shout out to my cali
fornians
hostas from california right
very relevant it's not the mask it's
this is a chain or a lanyard i believe
it's a lanyard
we all have to wear mass these days
the society we live in but what's really
really frustrating is that when you have
to take off the mask to you know take a
sip of water or whatever it might be you
either have to hang it from your ear
which i'm not a fan of also i found out
recently it's not the most sanitary or
you sort of have to like hold it in your
hand or put it in your pocket and i'm
not about that life i'm really not about
that life so my sweet friend made me
this little lanyard chain situation that
you could attach to your mask and
then boom
bada boom right
a book one of my favorite books the
alchemist
i i'm a pretty voracious reader i chose
this because it's one of my favorite
books i think anyone who's on the
creative path or creative journey they
will get a lot out of this book i found
this book because a friend recommended
it to me and i read it for the first
time about seven years ago as most
people know becoming an actor is is a
very arduous journey there's so many ups
and downs but this book just really gave
me perspective you know one of the main
things about this book is the fact that
through all the struggles and the
tribulations that you grow
and that it prepares you for what's to
come and that the universe is conspiring
to to help you fulfill whatever your
dream is when i read those words for the
first time it was really powerful it was
very moving and they continue to spur me
on and to really enjoy that process if
you enjoy that process then then when
you achieve whatever you want to achieve
it becomes all the more worthwhile
this is an emotion wheel
there's a piece of tape here because
it's currently taped to my bedroom and
when i say currently i mean not right
now because i took it off for the sake
of this video this is an essential for
me i think when you can identify how you
feel you can process how you feel and
when you can process how you feel you
can ultimately
heal i found it through
a therapist he recommended that i
start to really name specifically what
i'm feeling and so often times when we
think of emotions we think of oh you're
just happy or you're just sad or you're
just angry and of course those are the
main sort of core ones
but as you get further and further
outside of the circles they become more
specific and i think the more specific
that we become the better in tune with
how we feel and all the things that i
just mentioned i'll do an exercise right
now i am feeling
in awe
of this situation primarily because i
used to watch these videos and
it's very surreal that i'm
in one of them now
also feeling
a bit vulnerable i'm sharing my emotion
wheel
my bible
faith has been a big part of my identity
and my journey and it's something that's
really important to
my core values and my beliefs i think
it's really unfortunate and it's really
heartbreaking that this text
and the church
has been weaponized in many ways to
hurt a lot of people particularly those
from
disenfranchised communities but for me
my faith has always been about
love and and kindness and forgiveness
and compassion my parents gave it to me
at my middle school graduation there's a
lot of history
uh in this it's sort of been with me
through
the many ups and downs of life
unfortunately i i don't read it every
day my brother is a pastor and will be
upset that i don't but i try to read it
every few days at least once a week i
always return back to the psalms i find
them very comforting i think david
writes in the psalms
with such honesty and vulnerability
especially when he's going through
hard times and hardships and that you
know through all that he can still
trust
that that god is working for him and and
has
the best in mind for him things like
that uplift me and keep me on the path
my ranch
set of sweats
this is a sweater that has a heart made
of pizza and ranch and this is a sweat
pant this is the iconic hidden valley
ranch bottle now there's a story behind
this i posted a random instagram story
about how much i love ranch somehow
somehow
hidden valley ranch
found that story and they said we're so
glad you're a fan of ranch
we'd love to send you some things
and within the week
i got this ranch set i had no idea
things like this existed this is the
most comfortable
set of sweats to wear
i wear to sleep i wear it to the airport
i just wear it all the time essentially
is what i'm saying i eat ranch with
everything fries
buffalo wings of course buffalo wings
sandwiches you put me somewhere give me
a tub of ranch and i'll be fine i think
the ideal ratio for ranch to food is 75
ranch 25 food i love ranch
this is my journal
this is my current one as you can see
i've journaled religiously
for the past seven years that sounds
really intense but a lot of times it'll
just be a sentence or a paragraph
obviously i have days where
you feel it coming you know you feel the
emotions and the writing it just comes
and flows journaling allows me to
process my thoughts process my feelings
and yeah it's it's always so fun to look
back and cringe
at how embarrassing i used to be
years ago when i first started
journaling like 10 years ago
i it was one of my very first journals
and i actually lost it i think i left it
in like a taxi or something
and
this is not an exaggeration i couldn't
sleep for a month i had these nightmares
of
someone just reading my deepest
innermost thoughts
and it gives me chills it gives me
chills to this day not that i've written
anything bad about anyone in these okay
there's no hate in these just
thoughts that i'm processing okay
i feel very vulnerable again i told you
i'm getting in touch with my emotions
right okay that's full that's a full
circle moment that we had here
all right gq
that's it that's a wrap on the
essentials thank you for having me i
will feel feelings
after this